[Music]
Miley Cyrus's new music is finally here
and it is the hood the singer has been
teasing new music for weeks now and on
Thursday night she debuted her new
six-song EP she is coming guys
it's fire and it's just the first of
three new albums coming from Miley this
year check it out
[Music]
okay so her new tracks are definitely a
far cry from the more delicate sound on
her 2017 album younger now
the new sound is definitely a little
edgier without being all tongue out
turkey Miley of the past yeah let's not
do that again shall we the EP includes
the track cattitude featuring RuPaul
which is so sassy it had fans wondering
if she was putting Nicki Minaj on blast
with this lyric but Miley quickly shot
that ish down during an interview with
Capital FM they're both queens and
anytime you want to feel powerful and
strong that's my go-to cardi and Nicki
and she poked fun at the lyric drama
with some hilarious Instagram posts
including my fave alright but back to
Miley's new music check out unholy
[Music]
meet your new Friday night anthem party
up the street party about the street
even though there is no baseball and my
personal fave the most
[Music]
even in my
[Music]
she is coming is the first of three
planned EPS coming out this year she is
here is expected out in the summer while
she is everything will drop toward the
end of the year
each will feature six songs this is
Miley's first new album since tying the
knot with Liam Hemsworth last December
and her first new music since singing on
Mark Ronson's nothing breaks like a
heart last November
[Music]
in November a source told ET that Miley
was so excited to share her new music
quote Miley's new sound is something a
little more organic
she loved the pop but she went for a
more mature sound and sophistication in
her new music Miley has always been
great at reinventing herself she feels
at the top of her game
there is no arguing that Miley looks
sounds and seems happier than ever and I
am loving every single minute of it of
course we'll be here to keep you in the
know on all things Miley so be sure to
keep it locked right here on ET until
next time I'm Holly Stephens bye for now
[Music]